I know when you audition for Saturday
Night Live yeah you physically threw up
I did throw up because because it's
something you wanted so badly yes yeah
and also like when you watch it for that
long I mean it's similar to the
experience I'm having right now where
you've heard something for so long I've
seen you for so long and then be in the
room is very surreal yeah and it makes
you tighten up in a sense doesn't it
again because you wanted Saturday Night
Live so badly but yeah to walk into that
studio and you're like in now you're
meeting Lauren and you've just heard
Lauren's name 8 million times and then
there is I then be like totally loose in
art and I'm sure other comedians had
said to you hey man when you go in there
Lauren doesn't laugh that's that's the
thing I always hear yeah and you have to
sit there in the rooms cold yeah no
there's no audience yeah you got us that
there make this guy laugh we've seen
everyone audition yeah I don't see how
you can't throw up I mean well yeah but
it was good I got it out of the way
before I went in yeah and I heard when I
was in there I did hear a little bit of
laughter which was great I heard Tina
Fey distinctively laughing remember what
she laughed at cuz I thought you
auditioned twice you know what I did an
impression of Jimmy Fallon and she
laughed at that is he is he hard to do
Jimmy Fallon is that like you have to
whip out your like you can't do short
sonography is everybody does right you
have to find something kind of obscure
that no one else does I kind of happened
into doing it because I'm not an
impressions guy like primarily but the
way that we got the audition at SNL was
we were writing on the MTV Movie Awards
for Jimmy Fallon this is a crazy story
it's the best and he looked out for us
really a lot we were doing sort of that
we wrote the pre-tape stuff you know he
does like put himself in Star Wars write
himself in Batman and we wrote some of
those and he recommended you to Lorne he
did and it was because he heard me in
the temp like of the video that when
they wanted to show him to be like what
do you think of this and I was doing his
stuff so he recommended us to Lauren
into the show so how do you get the job
to write for Jimmy Fallon for the what
was at the MTV Awards the MTV Movie
Awards yeah and he did him twice and you
guys write for him twice the second time
you did it yeah we're up from Lindsay
Lohan the first year how do you get
my buddy Murray Miller my old dear
friend from summer camp right this guy
you've got good friends he's the best
hook me up so many times he's the one
who convinced me to apply to NYU he's
the one who convinced me to move to LA
so Fallon you got to be like freaking
out that it's Fallon yeah because here's
a Saturday Night Live guy yeah and he
brought all the SNL writers and a couple
of producers with him to help out you
must have been in heaven we were pigs
and [ __ ] were you nervous right because
you know you twenty-five years I mean I
remember 25 I sucked I mean I was is it
the worst I'd be 25 is pretty young you
get into a room with Saturday Night Live
writers and Jimmy Fallon yeah but it
went good I mean you kind of it's just
like everything you sort of test the
waters each phase and be like maybe this
will work and then when people respond
well you gives you more confidence yeah
I could imagine that room being really
tough it was all right though and you're
you're working for Jimmy Fallon Jimmy
Fallon thinks you're great he says to
Lauren I know these three great guys now
this is the amazing part to me yeah
you're the guy who gets chosen to
audition as a performer and your two
buddies in what's the name of the
company lonely the lonely island and the
lonely island comes from your apartment
right used to be yeah that because the
traffic right all around it so your two
buddies from high school say hey and
we're gonna go in as writers and digital
maybe do digital shorts and things like
that
you you feel inside how can you turn to
your friends who you've been working
with your whole life and you guys are in
this together and suddenly you're being
singled out to maybe be the guy on
camera and they're not yes an
awkwardness in that discussion yes I
will say the thing that made it not as
bad was that being on camera on SNL had
been my vocal dream for as long as they
had known me and it was decidedly not
their dream right like we all loved SNL
but Akiva really didn't have any
interest in being on camera right
especially not like live on SNL and
Jorma had done a lot of theater and is
hysterical but it wasn't like what he
wanted to do was do sketch so when they
say to you Andy you'll be auditioning to
be a performer do you guys go off in a
room and really talk about it and say
look what do we
do here well first they asked me to
audition right that's the where you have
to sit in front of lawn and do some of
your standup all that and the three of
us wrote my audition together I mean
it's always been the team it's been
really cool that way how long is the
audition it's like five to eight minutes
so you're not an impressionist but you
do the Fallon thing you have to do other
impressions just because that's the
thing on Saturday Night Live yeah I had
to come up with some who would you come
up with um I did Alan Rickman in die
hard
what is he [ __ ] sound like I mean
Rickman it was again it was all just
sort of shitty bit so the whole
impression was just McClane and if you
do that Lorne laughs at that yeah you're
in it was more for me the audition was
less about concrete bits that I was just
nailing and more about sort of the vibe
you created a fund mod that was my hope
but when you do Fallon do you have to
come up with specific material you have
you can't just go out there and just
start riffing it was Jimmy Fallon at a
funeral because Jimmy's such enough
because of meat and so when you did it
you had an audition again right yes now
how soon after do you have to audition
again it was like three weeks two or
three weeks so when you heard you have
to audition again do you sit there and
lose complete confidence and say oh [ __ ]
why didn't they put me through I've
never heard of somebody going on and
well this is actually pretty interesting
for people who care about that's an L
they told me they wanted they want you
to come back again the network just
wants to see you a second time and
Lauren and all this but you can pretty
much just do the same stuff you'll be
fine okay I'll just redo it maybe I'll
even do it a little better and then the
day before it or two days before it
I got tipped off like hey don't do all
the same stuff right and I was like oh
[ __ ] I have to write a whole new
audition in two days because Lauren will
think you don't have much behind you
right yeah yeah also I don't know who
told me to do the same stuff but that
was bad advice
that's an [ __ ] but somewhere I think
tipped you off that it's the right thing
to do to make new material I feel like
it was maybe one of the producers that
we knew from the movie Ward's okay but
in in the back of my mind now I feel
like maybe
do that on purpose to see if you can
respond under pressure right the show is
written in a day or two that's right so
what did you do what did you come up
with for who two days before well the
the thing that I came up with that never
existed before that is the dumbest [ __ ]
ever but apparently is what clinched be
the show according the Lorne yeah is I
was in New York and I had gone to a flea
market and bought these really tiny like
old seventies jogging shorts yeah and I
was [ __ ] around with my friend Liz
and doing a bit with her wearing the
shorts and being like an out of breath
jogger from the 80s
and like all I would do is say I was out
of breath oh my god so I'm so out of
breath
Gorbachev's really making things hard
huh all he said was like 80s shitty
eighties references then I threw that
into the audition and had it nan who
came up with that the three of you kind
of dr. Taylor Dow and I just came up
with like the night before man what
pressure and I'm picturing those shorts
and like your [ __ ] is outlined in them
right and because they're so goddamn
tight and they're pulled up I mean I
could just imagine look ridiculous and
the craziest thing is the second time I
did it on the show Paul McCartney was on
stage like five feet away from me how
surreal was not it was the first time I
had ever seen him and I like I walked
out to do it being like this bit is so
dumb oh hi Beatle